je suis choqué de découvrir sur les
réseaux sociaux les images filmées par
un détenu
quand on sait que les téléphones
portables sont interdits cela laisse à
penser que les échanges avec l'extérieur
sont légion oui je suis choqué de voir
des chaînes d'informations relayées
cette même vidéo en faisant abstraction
de toute déontologie
oui je suis choqué de voir ce personnage
dangereux incarner une sorte de héros
des temps modernes
salué sur les réseaux sociaux par une
actrice écervelée pour ne pas dire
décérébrés oui je suis choqué quand je
pense à la famille de la jeune policière
municipale tuée à ce détenu et en
particulier à son jeune fils madame la
ministre que comptez vous faire pour que
nous ne vivions plus jamais ce genre de
situation la crédibilité de votre
administration est mise à mal
il faut améliorer la sécurité faucheux
même l'exploit
l'exemple est ratée de notre système
carcéral c'est la confiance en notre
état de droit qui en dépend cette
évasion spectaculaire qui a été préparé
par un commando hors norme a
effectivement frappé les esprits et à
divers égards vous l'avez rappelé on
peut le comprendre
face à une telle situation il faut
réagir avec sérieux avec détermination
sans surenchère
le parquet de paris mène une enquête
toutes les forces de l'ordre sont
mobilisés pour retrouver le fugitif
et comme ministre de la justice je suis
responsable de la sécurité dans les
établissements pénitentiaires la prison
de réau vous l'avez rappelé est une
prison moderne elle a été inaugurée par
le président sarkozy en 2011
c'est une prison sécurisé et adapté pour
recevoir des détenus particulièrement
signalés des détenus particulièrement
signalés comme l'était redoine faïd qui
à ce titre bénéficier d'un régime de
surveillance très particulier je veux
cependant comprendre comment cette
évasion a pu se dérouler comment elle a
été possible sur la base d'éléments qui
soit irréprochable et qui soit solide
c'est pourquoi j'ai diligenté dès
dimanche une inspection qui me rendra
ses conclusions dans une dizaine de
jours j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
je tirerai toutes les conséquences de
cette inspection s'il est établi que des
signaux dallaire n'ont pas été prises en
compte
il y aura des sanctions y'a pas si
longtemps lorsqu'une loi d'envergure
arrivée devant le parlement
tout était fait pour que les élus de la
nation s'en empare en débatte la menthe
dans les meilleures conditions
ce temps est désormais révolu et
permettez nous de le regretter
en sept ans nous examinions une loi
d'envergure pendant deux voire trois
semaines
je veux prendre un texte en exemple la
loi macron belloy vous en conviendrez
cette loi avait pris le temps
parlementaire nécessaire trois semaines
à l'assemblée nationale trois semaines
au sénat en première lecture avec votre
gouvernement dans le laps de temps donné
pour la loi macron nous devons désormais
examiner trois lois de même importance
nous sommes sur des sujets fondamentaux
et vous donner au sénat trois fois moins
de temps nous avons donc beaucoup de
travail nous assumons le fait que le
programme législatif soit intense les
débats le sont également
que ce soit à l'assemblée nationale ou
au sénat sur tous les textes qui ont été
présentés il y a eu des débats des
débats que je crois riche des débats
auxquels vous avez vous même monsieur le
président vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs participer et je ne crois pas
que l'on puisse dire mais peut-être
avons-nous une différence d'appréciation
je ne crois pas que l'on puisse dire que
ces débats auraient été troqué un
quinquennat ces cinq ans respect pour le
parlement respect pour le travail
d'enrichissement du parlement c'est ce
que nous vous demandons en tout cas vous
ne m'avez pas répondu sur les agendas à
venir je le regrette
merci de prendre en compte la qualité de
notre travail permanent ici dans la
haute assemblée
il